c'est une opération ciblée visant une
zone spécifique de l'hôpital d'alshifa à
Gaza qui a été lancée dans la nuit de
mardi à mercredi par des commandos
israéliens l'objectif liquider les
combattants du Hamas et du Djihad
islamique accusé par tsal de dissimuler
leur centre de commandement sous le plus
grand hôpital de la ville au préalable
un appel à évacuer a été lancé dans des
haut-parleurs par les soldats israéliens
tous les hommes de 16 ans et plus levez
les mains en l'air et sortez des
bâtiments vers la cour intérieure pour
vous rendre au matin des colonnes de
Palestiniens sortaiit de l'immense
complexe hospitalier les mains en l'air
près d'un millier d'hommes ont afflué du
département des grands brûlés de la
maternité ou encore des services
chirurgicaux c'est désormais dans les
couloirs d'alchifa que la bataille
ferrage les soldats israéliens arpentent
les différents services visiblement à la
recherche de combattants islamistes en
tirant des salves de balles en l'air
selon un témoignage rapporté par l'AFP
des femmes et des enfants en pleur sont
fouillés et certains doivent passer sous
une borne de reconnaissance faciale
avant d'évacuer depuis plusieurs jours
alchifa et l'épicentre centre de la
guerrieurbaine qui fait rage à l'ouest
de Gaza l'établissement qui abriterait
près de 2300 personnes blessées ou
réfugiées selon l'ONU a été prise en éo
par l'armée israélienne qui accuse le
Hamas de s'en servir comme d'un bouclier
humain ces derniers jours les
générateurs de l'hôpital ont cessé de
tourner faute de carburant causant la
mort de Neu nourriissons secouveuses et
de 27 patients en réanimation selon le
ministère de la Santé du Hamas les
accusations de crime de guerre porté par
plusieurs ONG internationales sont
toutefois rejeté par l'armée is alienne
qui annoncé mercredi avoir livré des
couveuses de la nourriture pour bébé et
du matériel médical en marge de son
[Musique]
opération